[Music]
when I was 23 in my life was pretty much
a party it was that carefree who cares
nothing makes a difference what is
happening right now is what we're gonna
worry about which was the parties and
having fun and work wasn't really that
much of the equation my group of friends
we were young fun we're unstoppable and
we're on top of the world at that time
we felt we're bulletproof at that time
that we could do anything and then that
was pretty much there was no consequence
to anything
one day we're approached by a gentleman
that had a proposition my first
impression of John well-dressed
well-groomed flashy he was more than
just a businessman i sat with him and
the offer was put on the table would you
think about making some extra hundred a
fee to go to Brazil stay there for a few
days have fun you pick up a package and
we'll take it to hungry just get it and
take it here you're good to go
what kind of money fifty grand a lot of
money
let's do it
Brazil the hottest girls in the world
didn't think of the consequence drugs
didn't factor him he could have said it
a hundred times I probably wouldn't have
heard it it was not the oh my God look
what we're going to do it was we're
going to Brazil the first night we were
there we were noticed the moment we
walked in there it's almost like wearing
bright orange suits because of the way
were dressed and speaking English it
drew a crowd of people to us I don't
have a problem Pro Qing people so when
out on the dance floor and started
dancing and having fun and pretty soon
that just joined in two more people and
trying to speak Portuguese and dancing
and meeting girls and having a real good
time I guess you could say the rock star
lifestyle the nightclub the party and
not even thinking about what tomorrow
was gonna bring it was living back home
third day John showed up at the the
hotel we're leaving here
[Music]
the slums in Brazil are officious we got
out of the car and rushed us up into a
room in the hotel it was just get
yourself packed up and ready reality as
I'm now packed up with a ton of cocaine
it came time that our flight was gonna
be leaving and we had to be getting
through the passport area to where you
you leave the country we decided to get
in line separately standing in line
we're keeping an eye on each other so
out of my peripheral vision I was able
to see guy and noticed that one of the
police officers was walking straight
towards him
put his hand on his shoulder and tapped
him right under his arm exactly where
the drugs work the surprise in guy's
face was kind of like um I don't
understand it was over that was it it
was it was a very scary scary thing I
knew we're in trouble
I was scared because now we were going
to the most notorious prison in South
America the prison was divided up into
four different blocks pavilion one and
two rapist murders some child molesters
pavilion three mass murderers vigilantes
people that had killed numerous people
pavilion 4 where we were sent to police
officers common thief's
and few people with education
I had no idea whatsoever what was what
was in store now you're running a lot of
the risks of danger you're in an open
environment where there's almost no
control who runs the jail as the
prisoners in the guards they're just
there to make sure that you don't walk
out the front door